[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
ladies and gentlemen tom segura
what's up guys where are you at new york
i'm in new york i'm wearing this hat
because my alopecia is acting up
jesus
okay tom um i'm happy you're joining us
because i've been seeing you on the
internet has this become a thing huh is
this what will smith did do you feel
like was an attack on all comedians and
maybe setting a precedent for what you
can do or jokes being
not accepted in the right way
[ __ ] that cuck let me tell you this man
the idea the idea that your entitled ass
thinks
because your feelings are hurt you get
to assault
one of the all-time greats
because you [ __ ] feel and then the
the cowards the spineless cowards that
are in
hollywood in comedy we have a list going
of these [ __ ] guys anybody who did
not stand up
and say some [ __ ] for chris rock
we're going to ruin your [ __ ] life i
just want you to know that how come do
you feel like that was an attack on all
of comedy there
it's what it is
it's a display of entitlement it's a
very powerful
very wealthy
influential star who just decided
yeah i didn't like that i'm gonna smack
you
and then gets to sit down
collect his award
get a round of applause enjoy his night
it's insane it's like a gross
exaggeration if you see it all the time
you see entitlement everywhere and that
was on full display
for the world to see i have [ __ ]
zero respect for that [ __ ]
and i feel like more people need to come
out and say it it's unacceptable i sent
you that thing jamie about uh the will
smith thing that's in the independent
you a text message you showed it through
this was hot yeah yeah jimmy dore sent
this to me and it's like what the
[ __ ] are you even saying here it says
white outrage about will smith's slap is
rooted in anti-blackness
it's inequality in plain sight
what and it's in the guardian it's kind
of depressing
they just get sucked into wokeness yeah
it's just kind of like performative
pearl clutching hate no that was
violence if you think that violence is
cool you need to tell me where that line
ends is it just slapping can i kick
someone in the face if i don't like what
they say like where does that end you
just knew that this incident that was
between two
guys also they happen to both be
african-american at some point there
would be articles
blaming white supremacy
they're like dude i'm almost impressed
by the leap of logic where you're going
like dude that's awesome yeah it is
impressive that you're even going for it
well it took a solid 48 hours for
someone to concoct that like they had to
sit there you ever see that [ __ ] um
there's a meme of a woman there's all
these like calculations in the
background she's trying to like ponder
something that doesn't make sense
you've seen those that's them sitting
there like trying to figure out how to
put this and make it white supremacy
it's inequality in plain sight what the
[ __ ] are you saying quite possibly one
of the most shocking moments
in pop culture slash art
history
i don't you know very few things leave
me absolutely speechless but it was
funny somebody [ __ ] wrote to me was
going like i told you the [ __ ] pocket
you hear your reaction to the slap
hollywood's made you soft and i was like
so you turned into my podcast to listen
about gossip
about an award award show and i'm the
[ __ ] one that soft that [ __ ] brought
up a lot of [ __ ] for me
beyond being a comedian
but um
yeah i will at some point i just didn't
want to be yet another person
you know [ __ ] typing in all capital
letters flipping the [ __ ] out screaming
yelling and none of that's doing
anything for anybody my name is burke
chrysler and i want to talk i want
everyone to bring awareness to alopecia
it's my buddy joe derosa
you guys are acting like you're [ __ ]
tyson and holyfield
[Music]
oh
my
god you did it that was so sweet i'm so
sorry i'm so sorry i'm so sorry and
there's people who actually have the
[ __ ] balls to tell me
they're like you need to stay out of
business as it is in yours this is my
business it's my business more than it's
your [ __ ] business
so don't you think you can actually give
me a lecture what happens on the stage
tom you ever get into an uncomfortable
situation like that with anybody because
some of those corporate gigs i've heard
from comedians are like the worst so i
assume these types of situations arise
or no
i mean i've never had that in particular
happen i've had people try to stop shows
i've had people who are like that joke
is
you know horribly tasteless move on as a
comedian you know you just have to
navigate it sometimes
you just slam them or you you figure out
a way
in the situation you know i've been like
if you don't like this joke you can
[ __ ] leave
which is
honestly the best philosophy i think for
for comedy
i mean yeah i've had people i've been
booed off stage nice so yeah i mean it's
it's
it can go sideways that's part of doing
this long enough is that you're gonna
have
really bad [ __ ] shows but
but there's no excuse for being like
i don't like that joke
therefore i get to assault you
it's not the way it goes man you can't
let people just go around slapping
people
and
you just
you just this that is whether you think
it's violence or not it's violence it's
violence it's violence it was a it was
violence that happened on tv yeah it was
violent
um i think comedians should stop hosting
the oscars so they just tank because
it's the only redeemable quality about
that circle jerk yeah the only reason
why anyone tunes in is to hear ricky
gervais or whatever just yeah you know
bring it down to earth and have some fun
with it because otherwise we're just
sitting there
watching the most boring fake award show
where studios pay for those awards uh
did they really win it's a matter of
taste they don't even have a comedy
category go [ __ ] yourself some comedians
you can tell they operate on a level of
attack and i would say the medium itself
requires a certain amount of consent
like comedy you have to go okay i'm
coming here for a person to tell jokes
at a time where there's increasing
censorship around what can be said we're
not querying what can be seen where an
act of let's call it what it was
violence will smith has admitted that
himself can be broadcast around the
world along with some quite aggressive
invective at a time that people are very
concerned around what jokes are able to
be said it's interesting what is
forbidden and what is allowed who's
allowed to do what who's allowed to say
what when i mean i'll just let you know
if you come on my stage
i'm not saying we know i can't jump i
can't i'm not saying i can fight but
i'll bite your [ __ ] face off
i would tell you to get tickets but all
my [ __ ] sold out i make [ __ ]
i actually sat down at a long talk with
my lovely wife last night
about that [ __ ] took me [ __ ] back
took me [ __ ]
back and uh i gotta say the
the way chris handled that moment was
[ __ ]
unbelievable and the restraint that he
showed because
he starts to go like oh i could say and
he and the fact that he didn't
because it was lobbed over the net at
that point um for the daryl dawkins
break the backboard slam but then who
knows what happens after that and i felt
he chose the show in the event
over
you know
pride and ego and all of that stuff so
um yeah at some point you know
i'll sort it out but i don't know
whatever jesus [ __ ] christ
yeah i think that's it that's all i have
to say about the oscars
um other than when chris rock comes and
does a show in la i'm definitely not
missing that show
that's basically giving a green light to
the pimp slap to what what will smith
did yeah to chris rock that is not a
crime to do to your wife in russia yeah
chris rock should have [ __ ] hit him
back he should have jumped on his back
as soon as he turned his back like that
that just filled him through an mma
brain 100 you just take us back you know
listen man here's the reality you don't
slap a man in the face and then turn
your back and walk away unless you
should have never slapped that man in
the first place
because you're only slapping a guy who
you know can't slap you back that's why
i slapped him yeah that's the only
reason why he slapped him and then
turned his back and walked away look if
he slapped him and then stood his ground
and waited for a return and was ready to
go to war yeah that's one thing when you
slap a man you turn around and go back
to your seat
that is a sure sign you should not have
slapped that man yeah it's not fair i
just had this image of a movie like the
karate kid where chris rock just shows
up in austin he's like hey joe you know
treat me i was thinking to my friends
last night i was like imagine if chris
rock had a just a year of solid jiu
jitsu training under his belt and as
soon as he took us back as soon as will
smith turns his back he just leaps
and takes his back and just squeezes
will out before the [ __ ] before the
security guards can get to him will
smith goes out wipes that smirk off will
smith's face will smith you are a big
huge [ __ ] cuck i know you were
defending your wife because of all other
things going on and a lot of people like
she has alopecia i don't even know if
she does because hollywood people are
liars so she may or may not because she
looks smoking out with a shaved head
okay and the g.i jane joe yeah wasn't
the best but hey it was good enough it's
hard to be funny and that's itchy witchy
so i don't know if jada pickett smith
has alopecia wishes she might or she may
have just wanted to shave her head and
she said listen just in case the people
don't like this i'll just say of
alopecia they're all fraud pieces of
[ __ ] okay and the fact that will smith
was not arrested after he got slapped is
white privilege will smith is white
privilege it's just what it is and i'm
telling you if anybody if anybody thinks
that it's okay
to rush the stage when a comic makes a
joke it's not andrew schultz had a
three-minute bid on to open his flagrant
two on will smith and chris rock and it
was i mean it caught i mean it was after
the vicious attacks on chris rock last
night we think it's only right here at
the flagrant 2 podcast to defend the
comics honor to tell jokes so here we go
if you didn't see the oscars chris rock
got himself in a hairy situation he
shined a light on female alopecia while
jada's head shined a light on everything
else
chris was making fun of jada's baldi but
seriously how is will supposed to get
turned on if she has a woman's haircut
now i'm not saying that he's gay
he likes women specifically ones that
swim for pen holy [ __ ] all i'm saying is
last night wasn't the first time will
fondled another man to make jada happy
okay
that struck chris rock was actually a
metaphor for his relationship with jada
open when he wanted it to be closed but
let's be honest
last night will smith looked like he was
from the streets of philadelphia and
jada looked like she was from the movie
after all that drama will smith still
took home an oscar i'm talking about the
award not a mexican guy to [ __ ] his wife
while he watched in the corner
wow now to clarify will won the oscar
for best actor people were saying it was
for the lifetime achievement award and
no that's not it that oscar goes to the
plumber that unclogged jada's shower
drain
[Laughter]
now
i am tired of people not giving jada
enough credit okay it was actually jada
that helped will get in character for
king richard because when she gives blow
jobs her head looks like a bouncing
tennis ball
give it up to will okay give it up to
will smith he is the only person to be
recognized by the motion picture academy
and the citizen app on the same night
and to everyone saying will was probably
under the influence no okay he doesn't
drink or do drugs this is the only time
he's ever smoked a rock in his life
don't feel bad for chris rock okay he
was finally part of a hit white people
will watch
give chris rock some damn credit okay he
took that smack like a champ and next
year he's gonna be ready okay he'll have
more bobs and weaves than jada's wig
collection
now a lot of people are saying this
never happened during oscar so white
exactly okay the white oscars are
mind-numbingly boring or as jada would
call it a relationship with will
i think we can all admit this was
shocking okay because if there was gonna
be one chick at the oscars with a hair
loss disease that doesn't understand
humor i would assume it'd be amy schumer
oh my god anyway
let this be a lesson to you if you want
to keep your wife's name out of other
people's mouths make sure to keep your
hands off comedians look dude
it's wild that that guy
is getting away with that and i just you
know
it's just entitlement i mean you know it
reminds me i used to live in l.a and
you'd be uh you'd be like on beverly or
rodeo and you see these people in like
bentley's
double park or be like
in the handicapped zone
and they would i think a parking
enforcement person would be like
hey you can't park here and then the
person in the bentley goes yeah there's
no spaces
and you're like
yeah [ __ ] face that's what happened
go find a place to park
and sometimes
the person would get intimidated and be
like okay
and then sometimes they'd be like i
don't give a [ __ ] here's your ticket
and that's what will smith needs he
needs a big old [ __ ] parking ticket
how arrogant are you to think that you
deserve to go through life with no one
ever saying anything that you don't
agree with or like i want people to stop
saying that joke's offensive yeah i
wanted to start saying i found it
offensive because you've got our own
emotion because that's all it is you're
just telling me how you feel about it
yeah there's nothing intrinsically
offensive about this joke listen
apparently they worked it out like uh i
i read that they talked and will smith
made a statement and chris rock even
apologized and apparently they talked
backstage and worked it out which is the
best i don't think will smith should go
to jail i don't think any of that stuff
should happen i don't think they should
take away his academy award i think he
knows it was a foolish act everybody
else knows and i think it's one of those
learning experiences for the world it's
like a teachable moment right like the
whole world can see that we put stars
and celebrities up on pedestals but
they're just human beings and sometimes
human beings get pushed to the point
where they do something irrational right
and that's what he did he just did
something totally irrational that he's
completely embarrassed by more comedians
reacted on social media through
instagram and twitter also annie lebron
put up this picture of her and rogan
with the caption at jada pickett smith
and me the night before the oscars ricky
gervais tweeted dear tv and film stars
why are some of you so [ __ ] weird
you're actors some of you great actors
so just act normal simple ryan sickler
quote tweeted the oscars tweet saying
they don't condone violence of any kind
and said you allowed it you support it
and you gave him an award [ __ ] y'all and
will smith joe list weighed in saying
i'm just now finding out there's not a
ga jain two in the works and brian
redband also said i wonder if will smith
just opened the door to audience members
attacking comics when doing crowd work
which i don't think will be the case i
think a lot of people are gonna get
their ass beat if they start charging
the stage a lot of comedians reacting to
this pretty crazy stuff if you love the
world of comedy want to stay up to date
on it make sure you hit subscribe to
this channel joke world and also go
check out our instagram link in bio
thank you for watching and i'll see you
again soon
[Music]
you